boa tarde a todas a todos e ator disse
que não gosta de dizer meu amigo é de
marte
queria agradecer o kelson pelo convite é
todo mundo o pedex por tac ea vocês né
que trocar o churrasquinho de final de
semana o cobertor do netflix nesta tarde
chuvosa pra tá aqui partilhando com a
gente é eu estava conversando com kelson
ali que eu vou tentar dar uma
improvisada pelo contexto e pelas falas
que me antecederam e mudar um pouquinho
perspectiva de relação da do pensamento
dos reinados do congado dentro de uma
perspectiva mais política né
o que eu já me apresentou o rafa rafa
barros só entrou pólo de formação
congadeiro por devoção fulham por opção
e para brincar com os termos da
antropologia eu sou meio que
antropólogos nativo um congadeiro que se
tornou entrou paulo porque cresci no
meio dos reinados neodi os congados como
a gente mais popularmente se identifique
em minas gerais mas na universidade foi
me tornar o pólo e escolhi como um dos
temas de reflexão os reinados e os
congados mas tanto aqui em mariana e
diante esses três anos de tragédia
ainda sem qualquer tipo de reparo né
uma tragédia que a não apenas tirou vida
mas assinou culturas e modos de vida né
eu acho importante a gente tenta fazer
uma inflexão é pela minha própria também
em construção mais recente nas muitas
uma vez que a atividade minerária ela
diz respeito a uma lógica uma ótica de
vida né
há um pensamento muito bem situado e
organizado dentro da nossa história né e
do momento de construção de concepção da
vida moderna que a exploração a qualquer
custo
uma idéia de progresso que sem imprimir
o futuro sem medir as conseqüências
em contraposição a óticas e lógicas de
vidas que mantém uma outra relação com a
natureza e com as pessoas que essas
comunidades que foram destruídas sejam
elas comunidades rurais sejam dos povos
indígenas que foram afetados nem mais
abaixo no curso da água é representa uma
em oposição à outra né
e os reinados são nada mais do que uma
dessas outras formas de estar no mundo e
que podem apontar para a gente outras
perspectivas políticas outras
perspectivas de elaboração e de relação
com o poder instituído
é numa tentativa de reordenamento social
para que a gente de fato consiga
transformar a sociedade onde a gente
vive né então as muitas é a qualquer
ação se referiu é uma movimentação de
belo horizonte
quem é que já ouvi falar nas muitas
alguém levanta é então a gente chama
movimentação política que surgiu da
confluência de uma série de forças e de
movimentos ativos em belo horizonte com
o objetivo explícito de ocupar o poder
instituído a partir de uma outra ótica
de uma outra lógica tentando subverter
né é essa tradição que nos foi imposta
alegada pela colonização né
pelo processo de invasão das terras
brasileiras pelos portugueses que
chegaram em contraposição aos indígenas
é um processo de concretização dos
negros trazidos de áfrica né ea gente
conseguiu agora nas eleições eleger duas
mulheres negras a orelha carolina que a
mulher mais votada do estado de minas
para a câmara federal
a quinta deputado mais votado em minas a
mais votada em belo horizonte e região
metropolitana e andré de jesus que é uma
ex doméstica e hoje vai ocupar e agora
vai ocupar uma vaga na assembléia de
minas né
e é nessa perspectiva que eu vou tentar
então agora é um pouco subverteu que eu
tinha pensado para a gente poder
partilhar é essa fotografia
ela foi tirada em ibirité minha cidade
minha terra onde eu cresci região
metropolitana de belo horizonte
e ela contextualizada bem a permanência
de de uma tradição né que vem de muitos
e muitos anos mesmo em território urbano
numa grande metrópole brasileira
no caso da região metropolitana de belo
horizonte
mas agora eu tô vendo como é um pouco
difícil mesmo
a record ficou e aí a gente vai voltar
um pouquinho nas raízes históricas que
diz respeito ao processo de constituição
dos reinados o dos congados ea gente
chega nessa fotografia que diz respeito
a um acontecimento de 1.482 que foi a
chegada dos portugueses no antigo
império do congo na áfrica é é
interessante a gente trazer essa
reflexão é justamente para mostrar que
quando os portugueses chegam em áfrica
eles não encontram um bando de nativos
completamente animalizados mas eles
encontram um grande império constituído
com o sistema político complexo com todo
um princípio de trocas comerciais
inclusive com a existência de moeda
monetária para a realização de
transações e toda uma parada simbólico e
cultural né que compreende uma vasta
região da áfrica
e naquela fotografia a gente tem
justamente diogo cão que o navegador com
o navegador português que chega na
áfrica
de joelhos diante no mali sonho que era
o antigo rei do império do congo
reconhecendo o seu poder real nem ea
grandiosidade a grandeza do império é
que ele encontrou mas esse encontro
ele ele promove uma alteração muito
significativa e ao mesmo tempo distinta
que é de ordem simbólica e cosmológica
porquê porque os africanos com a chegada
dos portugueses tiveram uma leitura de
ordem mítica em relação ao surgimento
através do mar de navios dessas pessoas
brancas que segundo as suas orientações
religiosas correspondiam a deuses que
teriam vindo do mundo dos mortos que
ficava a lei mar então a relação ou a
visão a percepção que os congoleses
tiveram a partir da chegada dos
portugueses naquele território era de
que talvez aquelas pessoas fossem uma
espécie de dívida de divindades que
teriam volteiam retornado ao mundo
carnal dos vivos para estabelecer uma
série de relações com eles então a
perspectiva o ponto de vista que
orientou a relação dos negros africanos
em em relação aos portugueses era de uma
hora era de ordem divinatória né
era de total respeito enquanto no
decorrer da história a percepção dos
portugueses em relação aos africanos foi
completamente distinta foi de
objetificação de pessoas de seres
providos de espíritos
eles se tornaram mercadoria objeto né
eu não sei se tem alguém aqui que por
acaso estudou estuda história mas eu
acho extremamente significativo quando a
gente se depara por exemplo com os
testamentos do século 17 do século 18 do
século 19 no brasil em que arrolados
entre os bens dos fazendeiros
além das suas propriedades e dos seus
bens imóveis aparecem justamente pessoas
como propriedades que são a relação dos
escravos e das escravas né
é então os portugueses é em muito pouco
tempo eles começaram a desenvolver
talvez uma das maiores engenharias
comerciais da modernidade que foi o
tráfico da vida humana né ao trazerem de
forma violenta e arbitrária os africanos
para as américas e eu acho que é
importante também destacar que nesse
paralelismo de de relação e de
perspectiva desse encontro histórico e
civilizacional
a leitura é que se deu também do ponto
de vista do encontro de perspectivas
sagradas e eu digo isso do catolicismo
português e dos ritos tradicionais
africanos
ela na verdade proporcionou o surgimento
de uma outra ordem de relação religiosa
que é o que vai dar surgimento é aos
reinados aqui do brasil em especial de
minas gerais ou aos congados o essa
tradição então essa prática política
religiosa que se conforma no brasil ela
tem as suas origens as suas raízes
fincadas na áfrica partir dessa religião
desta relação de encontro sagrado entre
a perspectiva cristã ea perspectiva
tradicional africana né
sem qualquer tipo de sobreposição ou
intervenção colonialista eu acho que
existem orientações que se equivocou
muito ao acharem que os negros né feito
escravos eles foram completamente
submissos a uma ótica uma lógica de
relação entre o mundo dos vivos ea
esfera sagrada a partir de uma ação e
missionária colonizadora
os portugueses né enquanto que se operou
naquele momento que se arrasta até hoje
é a constituição de uma outra
perspectiva de relação com o sagrado né
o que em algum momento alguns autores
chegaram a descrever como um catolicismo
negro um cristianismo negro muito
particular e muito específico né apesar
do próprio termo esse termo cunhado por
alguns pesquisadores ser um termo
eurocêntrico né por trazer a perspectiva
do do cristianismo ou do catolicismo
como protagonista
no entanto o processo de diárias para
descrever a ação encontrou muita
resistência né
é ele não se deu de forma tranquila né
e sem muita luta essa é a representação
de uma das várias rainhas e guerreiras
africanas essa rainha e zynga é a grande
rainha do reino de matamba hoje
localizado no país angola né que atuou
de forma extremamente astuta inteligente
é na relação com os portugueses é ela se
batizou primeiramente para poder
estabelecer uma série de relações de
trocas e de contato com os portugueses
pra ter conhecimento dos seus costumes
das suas estratégias das suas formas de
de construção naquele território para
depois criar uma grande estratégia de
guerra e de auto-defesa a entrada a
interiorização do império colonial
português né
sendo um dos cinco nomes mais fortes é
da luta contra a opressão portuguesa né
eu acho importante é registrar isso para
que a gente entenda de fato a
complexidade dessa operação e dessa e
dessa relação mas vindo para o brasil
esses africanos eles também aussie a
climatizar em em território brasileiro
começaram a elaborar formas de
organização sociocultural em nossas
terras e desenvolver práticas culturais
e simbólicas é que os mantinham ligados
aos fundamentos culturais de origem e
uma dessas formas de organização foram
justamente as irmandades que se
instituíram principalmente em
territórios urbanos ou seja nas grandes
filas nas grandes cidades né e onde o
poder político eo poder e crise acho que
se fazia muito forte
foi uma forma que os negros sejam eles
libertos ou cativos é encontraram de se
organizar e de se constituir em
comunidades em organizações políticas
muito específicas e singulares né a
partir de uma outra lógica de
organização uma outra forma de
orientação onde o vínculo comunitário ou
seja a perspectiva comum app
a perspectiva coletiva ela era o
fundamento da ótica de relação e de
proteção né vínculo e perspectiva é essa
que também por exemplo fundaram os
quilombos é no país território de
resistência e de luta contra os
processos de escravizá são e nessas
irmandades as práticas de coroação de
reis e rainhas negras
elas não só reafirmavam né
a a província dessas nações
porque se tratavam não de objetos ou
demais mercadorias ou de pessoas comuns
se tratavam de muitas delas de famílias
nobres arrancadas do solo africano é
para o brasil e
se constituíam uma ótima uma ordem uma
orientação de relação é consagrado muito
específica
então se nas grandes cidades ou nas
vilas esses essas negras esses negros
conseguiram se estruturar e se constitui
enquanto irmandades nos rincões nas
favelas nas grotas nas fazendas e nas
grotas
eles foram se organizando em guardas em
grupos ou em comunidades quilombolas
onde essa prática religiosa e cultural
de coroação de reis e de rainhas negras
é em relação à outra ordem de sagrado
ela se estruturou né isso diz respeito a
uma ordem mágica e aquilo que os reinar
de euros os congadeiros chamam do mito
de origem dos reinados e dos congados
que é a história de regar de resgate de
nossa senhora do rosário né
eu não sei a que se algum de vocês
conhece é eu vou tentar resumir esse
mito de origem né
ele varia de região em região de acordo
com as características geográficas e
culturais nem as singularidades de cada
comunidade
mas em síntese ele diz respeito a uma
imagem de nossa senhora que surge no mar
ou na serra ou dentro de uma gruta ou de
trás do monte e os negros cativos são
quem primeiro avistou a imagem desta
santa branca cristã
eles informam os senhores da aparição
daquela imagem
os senhores então vão resgatar a imagem
de nossa senhora do rosário consegue
resgatar essa imagem é colocada numa
igreja uma igreja cristã católica branca
e no dia seguinte àquela imagem
desaparece e retorna para o seu lugar de
origem e estes senhores então tentou
inúmeras vezes resgatar essa imagem sem
sucesso
até que eles aceitam o pedido dos negros
de tentarem né e cumprir essa missão
e esses negros e negras né mais velhos
cavam tambores de madeira com folhas de
bananeira né e ao toque de um som com
passado eles vão encantando a imagem de
nossa senhora do rosário até que aquela
imagem então se debruça sobre um desses
tambores eles a levam para uma choupana
feita de palha muito simples e ali ela
fica e passa a ser cultuada pelos negros
esses tambores é na mitologia afro
brasileira são os candombe se que são
aqueles três tambores que estão ali ao
pé de um altar de uma irmandade rosado
de belo horizonte né é que seriam os
tambores mas do rito dos reinados ou dos
congados né ea partir de então desta
relação se expande
é o culto ea prática sagrada cultural
dos reinados e dos congados em terras
brasileiras né
mas o que eu queria deixar é acentuar na
verdade que eu acho interessante e algo
que eu trato é na minha cenário em que
não dá pra ver com a luz só tem mais
cinco minutos mas já tá acabando mesmo
numa das minhas é dos meus trabalhos é a
operação de inversão de poder que esse
mito ele transparece né
ao mostrar que vai ser a partir da
perspectiva cultural está grávida dos
negros né que essa imagem vai ser
encantada e conduzida a um outro
processo e gesto ritual de relação
consagrado né
ou seja é a força ea cultura desse
pensamento
é mágico e coexiste ainda hoje nos
nossos mundos
ele é capaz de ser superior a agência
daquela divindade cristã né
e eles então opera uma uma relação de
subversão da ordem estabelecida e
assumem é vamos dizer assim as rédeas da
história ea condução dessa prática
cultural e religiosa e o que a gente tem
hoje a gente tem hoje a manutenção né
dessa prática tradicional essa é uma
imagem tirada numa outra irmandade de
contagem ou siríacos né
esse é um jovem congadeiro um jovem
aprendiz né
a meta do capitão mor da irmandade do
seu antônio ciríaco né
e ele coloca pra gente e que eu queria
trazer aqui para encerrar duas reflexões
né
a primeira queda da perspectiva de
continuidade
né não existe tradição é dissociada do
processo de inovação e de invenção
então pra gente compreender a
continuidade destas práticas
socioculturais
a gente precisa entender que elas se
sustentam no fundamento
originário mas ela se á se alimentam
ativamente de um processo intenso de
invenção e inovação para se perpetuarem
no tempo né então é muito longe
inclusive qualquer perspectiva
folclorismo ante os congados ou reinados
negros se expressão enquanto uma forma
muito singular de organização social
política cultural ainda hoje na
modernidade né é e isso só é possível a
partir desse processo de invenção de
transformação e eu até a partir de uma
provocação do que eu só acho que ao
contrário do que muita gente é diz é eu
acho que os reinados não tão
a banda muito pelo contrário vejo várias
irmandades surgindo várias guardas
surgindo diferentes formas e
perspectivas
eu acho que apontam para uma uma
continuidade indefinida
tem um capital de reinado lá em belo
horizonte o seu ego do novo granada que
já é um senhor de mais de 80 anos que
ele diz o seguinte meu filho eu não
tenho a menor preocupação com o fim dos
congados porquê porque existência do
sagrado é infinita então como ele nunca
vai acabar essa dimensão do sagrado
então esses ritos também estão fadados
existir infinitamente
enquanto essa relação quando do sagrado
é existir ea segunda perspectiva é
justamente de uma de uma ótica política
e aí eu vou trazer de novo paralelo de
reflexão para as muitas porque porque a
existência dessas comunidades desses
grupos que substitui de forma muito
singular em particular ainda é no nosso
mundo contemporâneo eles nos apontam uma
outra perspectiva uma outra forma de
estar no mundo e de nos constituir
enquanto sociedade enquanto comunidade
então uma de um dos nossos grandes
desafios principalmente em relação à
constituição processo de elaboração das
muitas é justamente olhar para essas
experiências de vida para essas formas
de organização de partilha de comunhão
né que muitas vezes são ligadas
discriminadas oppermann permitem
pormenorizados pra bebê delas justamente
uma forma de reinventar o nosso fazer
político eo nosso a nossa vida em
sociedade
eu acho que assim como nos reinados dos
povos indígenas nas comunidades
quilombolas nas comunidades rurais nas
práticas e técnicas de agroecologia
então assentadas
é a nossa salvação não só política mas
existencial é isso agradeço e deixo um
abraço
[Aplausos]